hi there steve kaufman here uh we've had
a sunny weekend here in vancouver
uh temperatures have been cool
which is good because uh we're not good
because i'm going up north next week or
tomorrow going up to manning alberta
northern alberta where it's probably
going to be 25 or 30 below centigrade
um i'm going to talk a little bit about
what i would call or the post that i
made on my blog the linguist on language
blog
and that is to say that
you don't need language instruction to
learn another language i just want to
make this point because
i often hear people say
that
you know a teacher will say you have to
come to class to learn
or you know it's all well and good to
listen to the language but ultimately if
you want to speak correctly you have to
have formal instruction
or
i often hear too the statement that
older language learners
like formal grammar explanations they
don't like things to be loosey-goosey so
let me address
these issues here
you can certainly
learn in a classroom
i don't think it's the most efficient
place to learn but it can be done
but
it's not necessary i think the majority
of people who have learned another
language do it
exclusively or primarily outside the
classroom
that has been true since the beginning
of time i believe
and it's certainly been true in my case
either people don't go to class at all
or the class manages to turn them on
so that they go out and seek out other
resources things to listen to things to
read people to talk to so the learning
takes place primarily outside of the
classroom i think it can take place it
takes place entirely outside the
classroom
and as i say in my post there's three
things that you need to learn a language
you need the motivation
you need the time
and you need to
have some degree of alertness or
attentiveness to what's happening in the
language
so the
motivation of course is crucial it's
hard to learn something that you're not
motivated to learn
at the time and here i think
you know as i've said many times the
modern technology ipod iphone mp3
players internet enables us to get at
the language in so many different
situations so that we can use up a lot
of dead time which is certainly my case
with my russian studies it's mostly dead
time that i use
uh so we can find the time and of course
the motivation of the time we're
connected if you haven't got the
motivation you won't find the time
you'll say i'm too busy
the other thing is noticing the language
and uh obviously listening a lot you
start to see some patterns the brain
starts to pick up on certain patterns
just naturally
uh however uh you can do things uh to
help you uh flash cards i think the
things we do at link with the
highlighting in yellow of words that
you've seen before
can help i find now that i'm more
advanced in my russian talking to my
tutor and getting my report back with
all of the things that i said wrong
helps me to notice
correcting people's writing can help
them
notice
uh reviewing grammar can help you notice
sitting in a classroom can help you
notice
but the none of them individually is
necessary and i think the big thing
there is to do those things that you
like doing so if you like going to class
then that's fine but formal instruction
is not necessary especially if you don't
like formal instruction which happens to
be my case
now
i hear teachers say that that the older
learner uh must have this formal
structure but if i look at the case here
in in canada with these adult esl
learners
who presumably many of whom will say i
need the formal grammar explanation well
if that's the case why are they still
sitting in a classroom if that worked so
well for them many of them had 10 years
of that kind of instruction why are they
still sitting in a classroom
maybe they should look at doing it some
other way
and we have had learners uh adult
learners who have told me whether it be
with reference to
spanish verbs or or trying you know
getting
being asked to identify transitive and
intransitive verbs in english and people
a lot of people dislike that kind of
instruction so some adults may feel they
need it some maybe do need it
many who feel they need it may not have
explored other ways of learning
and many of them actually don't like it
so i don't think we can generalize and
and i think there also are teachers
who consider that the uh the the what is
done in the in the classroom is a bit of
a game just to amuse
uh
these learners and it's a game that both
the teacher and the student play with
with not very much in the way of
uh great learning taking place now some
teachers will say that other teachers
will claim that you can only learn in a
classroom and of course i'd get into
these great debates on this list serve
with teachers who feel you have to go to
these
you know structured linguistically sound
uh tesol programs where they do
sociolinguistics and all this other
stuff before you can
help your students learn and i say no i
don't think that's the case
and there was research i mentioned again
on my blog
that
in japan some japanese students who were
studying german
actually did better just listening to
stories they picked up more words just
listening to stories
than through more traditional uh
language instruction
and uh
certainly that's been my experience
um
there was another point i wanted to make
but you know i always i launch into
these things without any notes and
sometimes i forget
oh yes there was the case in new jersey
or new york where
um
in some high school they had these uh
english as a second language students
from somewhere in latin america
and they found that if they gave them
all ipods and had them listen to songs
or whatever they like to listen to in
english that those kids got out of their
english as a second language class after
one year whereas in a more formal sort
of structured environment the kids would
stay in those classes for five or six
years and i'm i'm totally persuaded that
if all the people who went to these
esl classes here in vancouver if they
could be persuaded that their language
learning was up to them
and that the best way to learn was to be
exposed to a lot of the language
to uh to listen to stories to watch soap
operas but but with a little bit of
system
in other words it's not enough to watch
something that you don't understand or
listen to something that you don't
understand and continue not
understanding
it is necessary to put a bit of effort
into trying to to mine this content for
words and phrases which is of course
what we do at link
and uh but
i remember too
a statement once i was at a conference
put on by the vancouver board of trade
or some organization i can't remember
which
for a group of um
chinese immigrant engineers yeah i think
that the
immigrant service organization's success
here in vancouver was also involved in
this thing and a fellow by the name of
edmund edwin wong who is the head of
training and development for the british
columbia employers association fairly
senior guy
he's a chinese origin i'm not sure
whether he speaks chinese or not
but he told these engineers and they
were all complaining about that their
credentials weren't recognized and so
forth and he said you know the employers
actually hire a lot of people from china
they know which universities
are highly rated which are not they
understand what your credentials are
worth the biggest problem is that you
can't communicate and what you really
should do is you should read
the cartoons
the comics
in the newspapers
and read them until you can understand
them
and when you can even understand the
ones that have very very few words
that means you've made it you can
communicate now those are the kinds of
things that you're not going to learn in
a classroom you're going to have to do
that outside the classroom through a lot
of listening and communicating and
talking people and so forth so i think i
kind of draw down enough
so i just want to reiterate then that do
what you like to do in language learning
and if you like the classroom and and i
can see why many people would it's very
social maybe you have a delightful
teacher and you have friends go for it
but it is not necessary you don't need
to go to class you don't need formal
instruction in order to learn a language
and i'm talking about right up to a very
very high level of proficiency
that's my view i look forward to
comments and criticism thank you